hey guys Greg here so I wanted to interrupt
really quick because you're doing a YouTube
channel for a while you're bound to have a
massive audio malfunction and sure enough
uh we did the headsets that were normally filmed
with they did not work properly so we had to rely
on backup audio from the camera itself so audio
not as good as it normally is however uh still
put a lot of work in the video and uh Andrew
and Tara they still killed it should still be
an enjoyable reaction once your ears get used to
the audio either way enjoy citizens of the reject
Nations we tear Air China gone along with this guy
words came out weird you say your name I'm fascist
excuse me I'm Batman I'm sorry Flash Gordon so I
wanted to repeat the most famous beloved lines of
this film from the trailer that I saw months
ago what a roller coaster that was wow what
you were timing your community
but I'll leave a comment and
then you know what's up you better bring that back
and also don't forget we call you super
super super super sexy when you get on
patreon because then you can sync up with
your in with your own copy and watch the
all Blue Beetle with me and Andrew Greg and
John cover exclusive stuff over there with
specific reactions and highlights and
you know just get super sexy get over
there you know what the deal is Blue Beetle
I think I watched a trailer I don't know a
lot about it I'm sure Andrew will open his
book of references you know this guy he's
got a lot I got none so I feel like we're
ready are you ready let's do it let's do it
[Music]
plugged into the Matrix
oh my God his face is so scarred up
cord Industries yeah
I did not know she was in this I think mine's
longer you think it's just tend to be for Sunrise
another decoy it's in there getting Man of
Steel Vibes right now yeah I love
how she's the only one in white
that's a good point whoa this is that
the Scarab which is yeah Victoria Court
missing okay so that's his way if that's the
obvious thing but where is he missing maybe
we'll get an answer that by the end of the
film or one of the mid-credit post credits
I do like all the cloak and stuff
like that's really cool it's giving
me Predator Vibes I love it yeah Predator exactly
Miguel okay we love Cobra Kai yes we say
no I'll tell him that's Loca even good news
and this is pretty bad news I can be joyful how
was your implied are you hungry of course yeah
that's all they had she is joyful yeah well
obviously this doesn't take place in the MCU
where I'd say that's it oh George Lopez his beard
is so long I'd say that's a reference to Ant-Man
if this weren't them to you he's had his tacos
now let him have the truth the truth yeah what
is it we're losing the house no wait till he
finishes the tacos they gave us three months to
come up with the money that sucks tripled we're
gonna have to bust our ass in the shop right
um Auto Shop's gone yeah wow you can
thank court for that double whammy
heart attack [Music]
why didn't you tell is
yeah I can understand why they normally I would
be mad at a family for not telling him that kind
but yeah I actually too I I understand
I'm not telling him that honestly I do
I love that good good family yeah but
I love like no matter what through the
hardship they're still sticking together and
still trying to you know yeah stay happy and
figure out a way because that would that would
break a lot of people I was supposed to make
it out I was supposed to get all of us out of
here thanks bro but I like the keys wow oh is
that Ace is that like an ace chemicals reference
that's where the Joker became the Joker [Music]
outside of the tracks and now they want that too
I mean she's got a point I'll get a
job not just any job but a rhyme John
a few weeks yeah like there's no way buddy telling
you in five years we're gonna be rolling in it
because we're gonna have the Mansion on the water
with the marble everywhere infinity pool I believe
in Jaime she did say the keys as in like Florida
right yeah I believe so that's what I thought and
then I saw the city I was like well that's not the
keys but this is yes okay got it that's a sick pad
yeah that's awesome in his imagination did are we
just gonna skip ahead or they actually have it no
see there's oh this song
oh it's in Spanish I love it or what
it's gonna say does he works I love it
hey girl hey I didn't know you were coming
oh carapax this is Ted's daughter my favorite
niece Jennifer [Music] the world has this
is her niece by marriage I would assume
that's what she just said yeah and she does not
agree with cord I guarantee they're probably
future of private policing
hi I deserve a luxury dump right now
all right nothing like a luxury dump
like if she's not at all worried about
her job right into the human brain so
you get connected to the Matrix this is it looks
old that's what he has that's what we saw
earlier oh cool security core can we lie
on all right we don't make weapons anymore
you are nothing to this company a brat in
her daddy's board seat your father was handed
a company I built my company you know what he
did just disappeared and left me to pick up
the pieces okay so they weren't married says
hey she said back away man uh
that was lavish oh [__]
I think it's time to find a new job oh boy
hey are you okay that was I appreciate the
chivalry but I can take care of myself okay
what a dick right she's a cord they're all
dead Jenny Port we're not old I'm really sorry
about this give me your phone let me give you
my number okay come by core Tower tomorrow I
might be able to get you a job somewhere else
in our company you know he has a degree right
you guys need any pre-lawyers you should hope
if he gets married that's a lot of money for
your family just saying girl can you that's a
lot of family's house real quick it's a lot of
luxury shits for her if they get married yeah
should I text her shouldn't I oh how many
followers that's it don't let it all stop
you even get more likes than that I don't think
so yeah you do I feel like I failed you guys
we're in a journey Jaime this house the
nepales they're just the stuff in the
journey what's important is that we go on this
journey together La Familia it's forever hmm
I love how positive and brave he's being and
again such a tough situation everyone has a
purpose you just haven't found yours so what's
your purpose then I'm still searching too I'm
just so scared we're having family moments
with the dad yeah I know how movies tropes go
I'm just worried because I like the dad a lot
yeah we'll probably lose him and that's gonna
cause him to go into action even more a hump
he's got to get over his Arc haha thank you
yeah I look like an [__]
just like everybody else
you're a game bro
[Music]
okay oh is that her I think so she's
trying to be like no weapons how do we
this is how it all begins
that is a cool design though yeah crop wise
oh oh is that what powers everything must be
ah nice time for your meeting with Jaime but
she's been there for what like three hours oh she
probably forgot that she had her yeah she's gonna
like run out of there yes me and you people talk
to their food done that I'm really trying to think
because I'm like I wouldn't put it past me not to
I'm not saying I don't think I do no I don't
maybe in my head I've done it in my head out
loud or like this looks good yeah I never
say it out loud though you just yeah yeah
dude I just stole some tech come talk to
me later let's talk while you have lunch
please without you said you'd do anything right
not open do not touch it don't
even look at it okay I'm just
gonna guard it with my life welcome
to South entrances you too with me uh
I thought they'd be gone this is a surveyor yeah
but doesn't the surveillance show that she handed
it yeah of course then also it would have to
show that she was in the there's no way they
don't have cameras inside the testing you haven't
looked is that not to open it she's not here what
blah
there's surprise yeah I've been eaten those
okay you guys are the ones that want to see it
oh my God all right guys come on like hey wait
oh my God whoa
cool
uh-oh whoa if you're gonna bind with him I think
he likes me yeah I think it more than likes you
that reminded me of aliens yeah [Music] oh whoa
yikes
[Music] yeah oh oh my God oh my God
this is dark
what's up what did he say I
don't know he's turning to Ash OH
oh my goodness this is like
it feels like a horror movie
whoa whoa
oh that's an awesome matchup with the poster
whoa oh my God [Music] holy to Molly it's like
the blue Iron Man adjusting pressure for host
protection holy crap he really is in space wow is
that my house testing great entry systems [Music]
I don't want to test this why why is it
so fast can you just let me down slow
oh my God yeah you would definitely
burn on re-entry I'm going that fast
[Music] whoa whoa awesome perfect engaged
cool [Music] you're gonna take down
the bridge kid I like that he doesn't
have control of it it's more it's more
grounded yeah because if he would have
had more control of it right away it's like
wait how it's like how do you even know holy
whoa
that was a dark night reference where
with the Backpage takes up side mirror
is he gonna mess up that car oh yeah
stop it's such a pretty Bentley that
beautiful Bentley I know has it hit you yet
oh I'm in so much trouble approaching um
cool cool
that slow motion shot is so cool though it's the
co oh my God Ah that's awesome the suit's doing
a good job not drawing too much attention
to itself this home is being demolished yep
hello hi me you could see the blue
uh the beetle was still in his back
that's a really cool effect though with
that that blue light it's almost like
the back of Iron Man just I mean the
oh yeah in the back whoa there you go
she's gonna know how to get this thing out of me
the problem is he just attracted because the suit
was malfunctioning like or testing there's
so many he attracted so much attention and
Court Industries is probably going to send
someone there is my guess no police what do
you think cord's gonna do when they figure
out that some Mexican kid has that type
of military Tech inside of them yeah it's
Dr insta she's Brazilian she lives at the
Regent Tower and she's single by the way live
alone if you asked me I mean important details
took your truck the Tacoma hmm
nice it's a cool truck [Music]
s
dude it's a family member you'll get it I love it
Jenny oh my gosh you'd think this
was a movie with that kind of timing
[Music]
okay there goes uncle's truck I don't
think he's gonna be happy enough
oh that's great you just hear him
outside yelling about his car I'm
fine
glad you tell me this now [Music]
be activated by just any person
he has to choose you so I'm guessing
it's chosen you no more blind dates
but we better move fast because my aunt
will kill us all just to get it back
subtle we are going to figure it out we always
do really is the rock of the family we've dealt
with harder things we can do this yeah I mean
he survived a heart attack and he's still down
in Tequila every night so like this is nothing
yeah come on now there's a place where we can get
some answers but we need the key and the quote
building I've been working on something that I
believe can help us huh cool I'm surprised like
all the damage they did that he did in the suit
before didn't like cause it to be a high alert oh
right the whole has to still be there but they may
seem like they cleaned up the house super fast and
like the holes weren't I call it why when you make
something cool you can call yours whatever you
want okay fair enough uh cupcake you want to hit
that yellow switch there hit the yellow switch I
just did you give me like once give it a little
always works when you kick things in classic move
awesome guys something's happening
ha that's great what the hell is this
I used to watch that when I was a kid probably
the same my mom I don't know when my grandfather
died Victoria thought the company would go to
her but he left everything to my dad instead my
father wanted to steer the company in a different
direction Victoria became obsessed with the racing
my father's life because seeing how opposite their
families are like when it's built on love and the
others built on his trust yep it's different
when you see the dichotomies of differences
this is the key
what is he doing here
should we run he's not slowing down watch out
watch out uh Blue Beetle yeah yeah it's a defense
mode cool oh it's closed just incinerate I love it
wow awesome that is so cool that transformation oh
is he gonna transform two into his uh he
probably is right or does he have to be oh yeah
yep here we go I was expecting this
till the end uh it's a now what the
hell is that thing the Olmec oh you're
going to regret that defending house
but see he's using everything off automatic
I'm curious if during the film
he's gonna get the manual down
kind of like the fight with
AI where there's only certain
things human instincts can take care of yeah
is he not hearing any gunfire I don't think that's
not I don't care how loud the music is [Music]
permission to take the host yes anything yeah
awesome [Music] where are you going come
on come on it'd be nice if talking was a
good fighting tool but unfortunately it's
not these kinds of battles nice I like when
we can Infuse hand-to-hand combat in these
kinds of battles damn it's got neutralized
what I don't know put the blades away
would you like to use a different
weapon no I mean we don't have to
kill him eliminating almost like
the T-1000 with those things stop
I'm not a killer command accepted
good yeah so his instincts are helping him
to take care of threats but not kill he
says I'm not a killer he'll eventually
have to probably get to that phase but
maybe him talking to bad guy in the
beginning was that a line from Iron
Man 2 where do you think you're going
what's with this guy maybe we'll see
his communication will actually save
something in these this fight really
is visually it's feeling so much like
the end of the fight environment one oh
although emotionally it's totally different he's
gonna kill him run him over come on Uncle when I
tell you pull that handbrake and pull it
hard oh is he gonna have nice Sideswipe
what would she do
oh
sick snap out of it I'm sorry I'm sorry
oh that's right he's always naked not
what happened back there my
it's like I feel it in my mind
I'm worried as Humanity might be at risk his mind
oh well so that's I'm assuming her dad's house I
wonder if I wonder if uh the aunt
kidnapped her brother I'm curious
so she could have the company I don't know maybe
oh or you just went missing doing it in one of
his thing I don't know a good call I mean I'm
sure she would be she was part of the big part
of the company it was left to him that'd be a
big reason why she would want to get rid of him
superhero like Superman a metropolis or
The Flash in Central City hey I know you
know those two yeah oh I get it though it's
Centric billionaire your dad was a great man
I had no idea like look at this it's like
Batman stuff but like if you had ADHD or
something hey that's my line damn you stink
this is your shirt come on I think there's
some of my dad's clothes upstairs I'm sure
he's the same size as your dad a long time
whoa self-healing nice
never getting rid of this Beetle out of my back
yeah he obsessed over the scare it but you would
disappear for days and one day he he left and
didn't come back it was very similar to Ant-Man
I'm a better kisser I'm going for the kiss in a
moment of vulnerability that's cold yeah such a
movie Trope yeah it was way too soon for that to
happen it's to become one with the other thing has
its own will okay well who made it can they help
us this wasn't made on Earth got us all night no
way see way it's alien yeah I don't really like
the turmeric I mean you can use it but whatever
the good news is I figured out how to get it
out why and the bad news is that you have to
be dead it's fusing itself to every cell in your
body it's completely coiled around your brain and
there's nothing on earth that could remove it
it's designed to protect a toast better than
alien and Aliens where it just rips out of you
all I wanted was a job maybe that there's a maybe
what Rudy it's all bad news Okay this [__] just
doesn't get any better for us I don't understand
why you can't I do feel for him though it's
emotionally a lot to take especially at 22.
I think he didn't ask for this like Superman
and Batman fight like they choose to do that
this was just yeah thrown upon him but I think
it'll turn out to be a blessing in disguise it's
just not in the monetary value he was hoping
for look at your old man he brought me here
from Sonora to get us all here and to keep us all
together and not that he wanted to he had to the
universe has sent you a gift I met and you have to
figure out what you're going to do with it maybe
this did all happen for a reason it's by far my
favorite part of the movie is the family dynamic
they're heading to his house where are they going
all right time to disintegrate that
that uh the old track suit modify get
rid of the clothes first because they're gonna
disintegrate again yeah that's a cool tracksuit
Up Up and Away web Shazam you said this
thing is gonna protect me right yeah it's
not gonna let me die no no I mean die
jump off the roof buddy let's do it
heck yeah I love that that's great the
amount of clothes disintegration but
then again he can't get naked in front
of the girl he's kind of got a crush
on don't touch my family get up let's go
up up Miss core we found the family damn
Uncle Rudy wasn't crazy after all
[Music]
I gotta imagine Jenny's gonna help
replace everything she's got money
don't say nothing come on Amy there he is I
could use that Arsenal right about now God you
never asked me I love it like others starting
to have a Jarvis Tony Stark personality uh
relationship I love it that's great let's
see what you can do Target the family no
I swear if anything happens to the Dad we write it
oh God she don't kill him
yeah that's more like it whoa
cool cool yeah that's awesome yeah I was like
oh the house has to be on fire now I was like
does that suit have water great tracking shot
circling around too oh my God this is so cool
ah oh no
oh no no no come on get get up
get up come on oh good job oh
no you are so rude you just had
an old man I hope that guy dies
he's the bravest dad ever
no oh my God thank you get rid of him I have
a weapon I suggest we Retreat No Way listen
to the vote the suit knows it's uh its
threshold oh no I hate it I hate it yeah
oh
damn it
crap
oh no
these are so soulless foreign
I know Jenny did not mean for any of
this to happen she was just trying
to get proof on what her aunt was doing
but this is a big part of her fault but
[Music]
it was literally The Rock is
hardly as a family Jenny does him
come with me if you want to live
I do like how it was grandma getting
them going yeah it's the oldest that
are in this family that have the heart of
it and and the glue of getting them going
yeah the oldest are the wisest
let's hope this court Tech works
I'm gonna try that from now on when something
doesn't work just just kick it a couple times
see what happens my flat tire kick it
whoa the beetle mobile cool that's awesome
dope whoa that's really cool
it's gonna say is this okay for the grandma
to be on like at this speed and all that
at her age honestly she looks like she's
having a blast this thing Bulletproof um
grandma just has a lemon always be prepared
guys want to see dad's toys yeah we do
oh yes we got this covered we are
now an army of support is that
good do these things work some of them sometimes
cool how are we supposed to
learn how to use these things
trial and error yeah yeah how do you
know how to hold that so perfectly
[Music]
okay don't mess with Grandma Pago is a
Caribbean island off the coast of Cuba
from Batista in the 50s places of
Fortress okay how the hell are we
gonna get in there yeah easy to get
and we got in already originally
the generators are here we could
blow them up and knock power outage
it's really interesting it's
great what are you doing
there's a guy who might have a heart might
be able to put him out of it she's like dude
I got rid of the light if we get rid
of Susan now that you've activated it
we can transfer its code directly into the omac No
No Miss Clark it could kill him Solace billionaire
you're going so fast here goes nothing
whoa awesome kind of looks
like a butterfly [Music]
[Music]
we need to move
beast mode oh wow that's awesome [Music]
yeah awesome giving me some
Justice League vibes yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's like I can't
miss right there right there
oh I want him to just go over a bunch of them
and lie down and squish them activating bug fart
oh oh gnarly
that's what I do to clear a crowd too
and when it's complete kill the kid so heartless
oh wow that's a lot oh good you guys gotta just
ruin that I'm really getting Matrix but how
oh this is where they gotta knock
out the oh yeah he's powering it
up okay his pulse is dropping we'll just fix it
brain break off and get out of there send
me a flashback or is he gonna see his
father hey I'm so sad it doesn't
always try to be in help me with these
oh boy
it's time for you to accept your destiny guy man
because he's never wanted to have the suit or
be part of it how am I gonna do this without you
so beautiful
oh it's his dad's necklace oh these
brain waves they're sinking with
the scarce frequency right there they're connected
yes [Music] awesome you're becoming one
oh wow I didn't realize it was
already at a hundred we've got
the code the transfer's complete code is ours
oh damn yeah he's gonna be way
stronger than before now [Music]
oh boy loose are gonna destroy the other
ones right oh good he's there so he can
get good that was a great transition
yeah that whole sequence was gorgeous
yeah it was very emotional again to
me that's been the biggest strength
of the film is the the family Dynamic yeah
it's the emotion of the film and the Heart
Second Battle now my name is you're
gonna let him go open the door
love it in your family and get off
this island okay what do you mean
my family good job we knew that look
in the beginning with that guy would
like somewhere tell her what your name
is it's not sunshine it's Jose Francisco
[Laughter]
nice
oh no okay all right
oh
wow
no no no no no no no okay good
are they separated though yeah
she she pushed her out of the way I think
Jenny's gotta be on the other side right
Transformer like voice a
little bit Yeah Megatron yeah
I feel like he's about to delete her just doesn't
feel like a person who's gonna take orders anymore
[Music]
yeah just keep running kid
Cobra Kai karate
we're just the right minute of course it's
a movie oh no his grandma or his mom someone
yeah so dope [Music]
thank you
I got this I love everything
that happened right there
oh my God that's awesome
I love it it's a great movie moment so fun it's
a great movie moment not to be a Debbie
Downer but it's in her son just Bentley
like I know I'm being a Debbie Downer she's
getting but it was Revenge yeah no no that's
true Sweet Sweet Revenge no no for sure for
sure she's letting it out right now too for sure
a lot of girls gonna have to save Jen
she's gonna do it with her crazy arm
oh I bet you that sound was her punching
through the rock oh it could be red yeah
with that that thing yeah I want you
both to get it together use the pain
we're feeling and and turn it into
power I want you to go back in there
[Music]
use it use the first there you called
it yeah I'll get it damn nice job now
you got to use the shield if they shoot at you
hopefully you can switch back fast enough okay
starting to break down after too much
hopefully it was just a flesh wound
I love the music change right
now it's awesome get the hell
away from my sister you ready that's awesome
yeah nice yeah they're really
working in tandem together
whoa nice
whoa oh
[Music]
damn
nice that's amazing get them all for me
whoa three for the price of one
get over here yeah it's a little scorpion
get over here that was great yeah get it
[__] that for a [__] foreign [Music]
[Applause]
this damn he made the Miyagi dough mistake
earlier on he showed Mercy yeah I don't
know if he's gonna do that this time
yeah
wow
nice
wow you do not deserve this power I mean
you're the only reason you're here is because
of his power bro that line was straight up from
Incredible Hulk deserve this power give me a sword
ah so I can make whatever weapons I want
huh whatever you can imagine oh cool nice
huh it's like I got a college degree I
can think of a lot of things [Music] whoa
nice
wow cool that was a great move yes
okay it's a little harder than I thought yeah oh
[Music] regenerative systems critical [Music] um
whoa that's the body slam I don't know
off your future family makes you
win no that's what makes him strong
oh [__] oh [__] is right
all right when he gets into protective
mode yeah you better watch out
[Music]
whoa
oh yeah I want to see what this book
you're gonna side with that edge keep track
over your own family I wish the
Ted were here now to see this
oh what how are you gonna
get out oh they're in the
bubble gum okay grew big I guess yeah whoa okay
he's raging now get it oh this
is superman-esque I love it or
you think you would threaten my mother nice
control buddy
cheese what are you doing we're not
Killers what an interesting card for the
I unlocked his memories yeah he's also a
family and he was probably forced into this too
oh he's had a tough life
oh God that's sad but we saw that locket he
had uh I feel like he had a wife and okay okay
oh is his mom and him no
[Music]
oh boy
what's so sad you're wrong
I love that I have for my family it's my
strength that's what makes me fun Familia
huh they come in here he's maxing out the energy
reactor in his suit I advise me back away oh no
stop now
sacrifice this must be
together yeah wow oh my God you better fly buddy
whoa
and she's strong to be holding that too
must be on a good workout plan ah whoa well
the it's it's titanium armor probably some kind
Grandma I didn't know you were such a badass
okay so that nitpick I had earlier was this
is justifying it much more now I'm looking
forward as I was saying will will no longer
make weapons it's not about taking from the
community we're giving back to the community
you can start by building them a new house okay
and look at this we always do I love that
he's wearing his dad's necklace it's sweet
I know he's gonna be dating Jenny but
she's gotta help out somehow she was
responsible in certain manner I'm sure she will
where am I we don't have a house I think it's
time to return the edge case of the people that
made it great it sounds like the Reyes family is
rubbing off a little bit on Jenny cardinal cord
Industries will fix and give you back your house
thank you that's here Rudy what's
this new car I got you a new tailgate
wow it's blue on the nose no Rudy I gotta go
yeah [Music] how about I walk you up not such a
good smile that was smooth where are you headed
to my dad's what if I gave you a ride oh I feel
a surge of blood rushing towards your mid feet
what's it say
this is a more appropriate time to kiss I
like cats backlit and the wind's blowing
I would always make sure I wore the
worst clothes possible hang on hold on
I'm so scared me too I'd be like holy [__]
yeah no I'm taking the motorcycle
oh my God I'm not doing that
okay hey we got a Gordon here heck yes that was so
fun I loved it I like I also love it at the heart
of this movie is all about love and family Familia
yeah and they really like a lot of movies try to
like kind of uh put that in there like love and
family but they don't actually show it this movie
showed it by bringing in all of the family members
to actually play a huge part and it's not just
Blue Beetle in in taking down the enemy right yeah
um as I mentioned at the beginning I don't know
a ton about the character of Blue Beetle but that
was my favorite part of the film excuse me it was
uh the family aspect that excuse me we'll come
back to that are we gonna see what happened to
Ted the father let's see the original Blue Beetle
has he been hiding in plain sight the whole time
[Music]
is he inside that thing and that's why the pillows
are covering the ding dong with the belt or
my computer
very subtle tell my daughter I'm alive Ted Court
he's like I have to say the first name and last
name um first of all it's giving me credit I
called it you called it I'm sure that most people
call them you call a lot of things no no no no no
I'm just saying I'm sure most people were able to
predict and the mid credits or post credits that
uh the uh was gonna involve Ted Decor that was
uh they're pretty sure that was obvious oh yeah
yeah but still uh like I said earlier I I don't
know much about the character of Blue Beetle other
than the little bit I've seen on Smallville and uh
in Injustice 2 and I did like what I saw for the
little bit there but um I I just love again I'm
always a sucker for a good family story and I just
I love the infusion and the dynamic between the
family uh the father was I mean again I love the
whole family they were also great the grandpa was
such a badass yeah um but I love uh especially
the dad he was such a rock I mean having the
house being taken away from them I mean the triple
the tax or whatever uh and then the heart attack
that's just having to kill after that um but still
being such a light of positivity like through all
the hardships that they're going to because that's
what they needed and like that's just a good
lesson for them even after he's gonna be gone and
I know that was kind of movie trophy okay we're
having our family moments and we know we gotta
lose them and obviously very movie trophy but
still even though we knew that was gonna happen
it's that it's the way they executed it that you
know and I was just so invested in him and the
rest of the family that even after it happened I
was like okay it's the lessons he taught them so
that you know when him and uh forgot the name of
the scare of the Kaji or whatever the name oh yeah
the Scarab yeah yeah whatever it is um that when
the infusion did happen and when he sees his dad
in the afterlife I'll uh Black Panther or whatever
uh it's just like it was really earned to me um so
that like you know when I I just I really bought
that moment and like just the lessons again that
he he learned from his father and like no I it's
not only that I've got to infuse with this thing
and accept my destiny but also that I've got to
become the man of the family and and be like the
father as well uh kind of thing um yeah the family
so I just I like the two lessons that he had to
learn in that about you know Destiny and that
kind of thing and the positive light that we that
I've got to be not only for my family but on the
world yeah and I like that they brought in their
own culture like in the flashback with the dad
um the the way that he's all lit by the candles
and they already had like a remembrance Corner in
their house even when they were all there together
so bringing their part of culture and the way they
that the flashback happened and that the dad
was basically saying I know now what my fate
was is to have those heart attacks and to die so
that I could be here with you and send you back
for your own destiny absolutely which was it's an
amazing message and it's really it was that whole
scene was really beautiful the colors it was it
was the world disappearing from from behind them
right it was like they were on an island and
the world kind of going away to force him into
space to to basically meet his like Blue Beetle uh
personality that'll have for the rest of his life
kind of a thing I really love that whole thing
about like you know his uh Jaime you know the
humanity in him you know wouldn't allow himself to
delete anyone or specifically that the right that
main villain that he was fighting throughout the
film and then you know again I'm sorry that I keep
forgetting the name of the scare but whatever Kaji
or whatever it was um you know was trying to Hill
throughout the whole excuse me delete throughout
the whole picture and then like towards the end
it reverted like I did not see that coming and I
always love when I can be shocked and twisted or
whatever you want to call it in films but in a
satisfactory way and I really love that it was
kind of like a character Arc for the Scarab itself
yeah but in again just done in such a satisfying
way and I look I just did not see that coming in
any way because again you could feel his anger and
you know even though he didn't particularly delete
his father you know he was part of the team that
you know was involved in doing it so you could
understand Jaime's rage and anger and any one
of us in that situation would have wanted to do
the same thing even though he wasn't a violent
person and always you know looked at deleting
human beings as a very last resort so like again
his rage and anger were totally understandable
and even like I'm sure either of us would unders
like almost doing that of course in that situation
I do feel though with that villain um again I do
like at the end what they were showing with his
family I did feel a sense of sympathy but to me
it was I mean I know the film wasn't about him
was about Jaime and his family and his journey
um it was all from his perspective but I feel
like it was a little too too little too late
in terms of just showing all that stuff I would
have liked a little more about the feeling it
didn't even need to be even if it was more in the
middle of the picture I just feel it was a OneNote
generic type of film and even Susan Sarandon's
character it's just very one note I did not
care about it right at all um she was obviously
fantastic actress I've enjoyed many films version
performances but I just did not care about the
character in any way shape or form yeah I'm evil
and yeah I'm like okay it's kind of like when you
when you see the foundation that they set with him
um when they go back to his family and he's
remembering it it's like any Disney or Pixar
film hold on we're getting to soon yes those creds
the cartoon we wanted they're the animated film
are they still watching in the security booth
[Music]
I would love it if Jaime and Jenny
you're watching this on date night yeah
oh that was great um oh don't touch that now we
should react to that I was gonna say how it's
like every Disney and Pixar movie right you show
the foundation of the family before and the sad
stuff that happens so that as we're following the
character you feel a little bit more for them yeah
um it's the same thing they didn't really show too
much about um Susan like with her brother and why
it was so bad we were just told it so there was a
lot of exposition there of of us being told what
the relationship was like but I think specifically
with him and the suit it's that he taught the suit
we were waiting for that moment when it's like
that they're supposed to link up the suit is
teaching him so much but in the beginning we we
realized the suit is so intelligent it does learn
from Jaime and that in the very beginning he's
like we are not killers and the suit was ready
to become a killer but it learns from its owner
so in the end when it protects him and protects
like basically the moral code that Jaime set up
for the suit in the very beginning without him
knowing he's setting up a more code is the suit
saying we're not killers and reminding him that
we don't do that you know it stopped him there
from uh which we all know your emotions can get
you in the worst possible places and he was in a
place that it was going to get him nowhere and he
would have not felt great after that fact so it
was cool that the suit came for him and set kind
of this moral code that we now see yeah he is he
is not a killer um and I thought a little bit with
with the uh the villain dragging suits random
like into the fire I knew that he was probably
gonna go hey let's just go join my mom because
like what am I gonna do here now if I have to
like serve her but I did I I did like there had to
be at some point where Somebody's gotta get rid of
her otherwise she's just gonna keep coming back
right as the villain and it was a nice move to
set up the girl to be like a CEO I just um I guess
it's it's kind of cool to see it like she made him
and now he's like well you know I'm getting ready
you know um wasn't like a huge surprise to me but
I I still liked it yeah yeah I mean that's that
would probably be I mean there's a there's a lot
there was a lot of predictable stuff for sure
in here um but I I really do agree with you uh
from her perspective and her hate hair hatred
for her family and her brother uh I mean that
was a lot of exposition more telling rather
than showing I wouldn't um even I again I
know it's anime's story and his family but I
would not even mind it like even a flashback
yeah I know they told us yeah yeah and I I know
they showed us like hey they gave everything to
her or to him to Ted and kind of like threw her
and I I could understand that resentment like I
get that I if that were me I wouldn't be happy
about that either but if you show some kind of
a flashback scene maybe Ted's being some kind of a
dick I'm like oh my God like okay she's still the
villain but Ted's being a dick about this like
I'm kind of like I'm not rooting for her but I
really understand her motivation and like I I get
it now like why she's doing what she's doing like
even from this one flashback scene right now kind
of thing so I think you make a really good point
like that would have added a lot more Dimension to
her character in terms of like you're just you're
no just because she doesn't want to go along with
your evil right yeah and that came around quick
I think the only real um Insight we got to her
is when they cut to um one of them looking at a
picture of her which Susan Sarandon had dark hair
she looked a lot younger and they made the comment
saying she was different back then meaning um I
feel like she in the video we kept saying like
human humanitarian like she was a humanitarian but
I think then she was already set in this way of
like I'm the CEO and I'm getting my brother really
screwed me over versus before I think it might not
have actually been her brother it might have just
been the choice of like who the power was given to
yes and that power being given away uh really is
what set her off and it might not have been her
brother at all and maybe they didn't maybe they
didn't want to reveal it but they still could have
given us maybe a little flashback of just maybe
when they were kids or how much the the whole
businessman meant to her and why the power being
take taken away from her would have pushed her to
where she is today and again you even could have
had a scene too where like you see that the father
is uh the hurt Susan Sarandon's father is talking
to Ted saying you know I could never give it to
Susan whatever I forgot her name uh her character
like she's too unstable like that sets her off the
deep just something like that whatever there's
so many different things you could have done
um like that um and yeah I know and again I
kind of said this during the reaction I just
love seeing the the dichotomy and differences
of the family Dynamics between the two different
families uh it's interesting to see uh you know
you got the the loving family of Jaime and then
with Jenny she's in such a screwed up I mean
obviously I would assume Ted was so loving to
her towards her I mean you could see you could
see how much love Jenny had towards uh him but
obviously with uh Susan Sarandon being her aunt
I mean that's completely a torn family there so I
I just love seeing the difference and like and
how again it was such a strength behind me and
you know uh obviously you know for uh for Jen
he was just something she had to work against
um but yeah yeah but again I I just I love that
was my favorite part of this movie it's like
it's not the the cool visuals or the cool fights
and high-tech stuff you know when they're in the
Blue Beetle suit and all that like that I mean
it's cool to look at it's entertaining but the
family Dynamic and the emotional stuff that's
that was my favorite part of the film by far I
mean you guys always know I always say it if the
movie doesn't have heart I kind of check out this
movie had a lot of heart which I fully appreciated
and I think what really represents the family is
towards the end when they welcome her in I mean
she was initially an enemy right she brought kind
of these problems in in you know on the on the
outskirts to their family and they lost a lot
during that process but um the way that they are
built and their own moral code which fed into him
and then feeds into the suit and feeds into that
this is is all just like a blessing for the entire
family and it is his Destiny and now we'll be able
to like protect them it's nice to see them like
take her in and then her be able to give back to
them in a really huge way absolutely great Point
again that that moment at the end with the suit
where she infused her like learning the moral code
and putting it I mean that really was one of them
I I was so shocked and surprised by that in all
the right ways I I just really wasn't expecting
that and I am so happy that they put that in the
film like that what a smart choice like yeah just
real like I just wasn't expecting the scare of it
sorry again the name I just wasn't expecting the
Scarab to get that character Arc itself right I
loved all the conversations they were having I
know it kind of felt a little Jarvis Iron Man
but what I mean it is what it is the same kind
of thing but yeah yeah exactly but I I just I
love the way again their their relationship kind
of just like progressed throughout the film too
and as I got comfortable with each each other as
he like you know made it his Destiny to be the
Blue Beetle but again that was one of my if not my
favorite moments uh in the film was that moment oh
yeah I loved it so much and the grandma just the
grandma man that's awesome 10 out of 10. I know
I made that little nitpick like why why isn't she
emoting a little more sad because her son just but
you know on the flip side again she's kind of
letting it out right there and like having a a
fun little moment and then afterwards when it was
all when the adrenaline had died down it was kind
of back to being said so I'm glad they put that
back in there I was like okay now it's a little
more grounded that makes more sense so yeah I'm
sure a lot of you were like shut up lover ever
moment I I admit that was I know I'm seriously I'm
glad that they put that moment in there where it's
like okay it's adrenaline has died down it's time
to you know be sad now about uh what what has just
occurred so right yeah yeah they had to kick it
into gear um I would give it I'm gonna give it an
eight out of ten I was gonna go maybe eight maybe
even 8.5 I I really liked it I thought I thought
it was a blast and specifically because it had
a heart it made it extra fun I think I'll stick
to eight eight out of ten it is a fun time what
about you I probably go like a seven out of ten
seven out of ten yeah very good still a good score
yeah still a good score a good movie we had fun I
mean any last stops before we get out of here no
just uh I'm if they do make us it was a good first
entry into the James Gunn Universe I know a lot of
people are not uh exactly enthusiastic about that
just because the whole Henry Cavill thing which
I'm not I wasn't the biggest fan of of course
I'm looking forward to his version of it which
comes out of my birthday in a few years to say
um but uh I again for I I really love to show up
by the way we didn't even talk about Jolo as uh uh
Jaime he did such a terrific job and he's great
it's gonna Gail and Cobra Kay everyone in here
was very believable really grounded great acting
in the beginning I was a little worried about uh
Jen it just initially I was was like oh who is
this girl do I totally believe her she dropped
in and then she did and she was really good at um
being emotional which is great um which I really
thoroughly enjoyed but I I really liked everybody
yeah and again really quick not knowing too much
about this character if they do make sequels
to this film maybe in the second film or even
a third film to even get that far I would love to
see them play around like again the psychology and
emotionality in terms of like what does this do
to hide me like maybe play around with the dark
side kind of like I'll uh you know when Spider-Man
gets the black suit and kind of goes like all uh
emo type of thing I'd love to see them play
around with that version of the character
um but overall I thought this was again the the
family Dynamic I thought that was the heart of
the film I was my favorite part and I love that
moment at the end where the Scarab just uh you
know reclaimed and kept his Humanity I thought
that was just such a well executed and such an
earned character Arc for the Scarab it was yeah
just didn't see that coming I was so thoroughly
really appreciative and surprised by that and
uh yeah really good that's it we love it leave
a like leave a comment you know ring the bell
tell us we're great we love you so much be cool
be nice be kind enjoy kind of spooky season
almost yeah that's it we'll see you soon bye
foreign